Mars the company that makes m m so they
come out and they're like okay our
cartoon characters which have been a
feature of our advertising for a long
time and they're just like little round
chocolate candies with legs we have
realized through some deep reflection
that they're sexist and the female
characters are wearing like sexy boots
and now because women matter and women
in leadership are so important we're
going to put them in frumpy flat sold
shoes
again I'm a personally a supporter of
the M M's company I mean I
single-handedly keep their stock price
high so I'm not against M Ms but I just
made the point that women can be in
leadership and still wear sexy boots
there's nothing inherently contradictory
about that you can have women who are
still feminine or whatever leading
things and I was mocking I was just
mocking and I was just joking I mean I
you know uh but apparently people got
all got all exercised fine with me